[Musica]
io sono un astronoma e quindi vi metto
davanti a un cielo stellato un cielo che
ovviamente potreste vedere a cortina che
è famosa per la l'ottima qualità del suo
cielo
se non ci fossero le nuvole ve lo
ricordate perché la prima serata serena
vi invito a fermarvi un attimo a godere
della bellezza del cielo e lasciare che
vi sorgano delle domande perché il cielo
fa sorgere delle domande fa anche
sognare ma le domande possono essere
molto legate ai sogni e la domanda che
voglio che vi poniate adesso è chiedervi
che rapporto abbiamo noi umani con le
stelle per mettervi sulla buona strada
v vi invito a guardare questo questo
quadro un pittore americano greg morgue
molto vicino ai temi astronomici di fa
vedere una spiaggia di conchiglie contro
un cielo stellato quello che il pittore
vi vuole dire che c'è un rapporto
diretto tra le conchiglie le stelle
perché il materiale del quale sono fatte
le conchiglie cioè il carbonio il calcio
l'ossigeno l'azoto è stato sintetizzato
dalle stelle non non esisteva
nell'universo primordiale esiste perché
le stelle l'anno sintetizzato poi le
stelle lo rilasciano nel mezzo
interstellare
ci sono molti modi in cui le stelle
fanno dono del materiale nel mezzo
interstellare equa vedete una stella che
si è gonfiata talmente tanto che perde i
suoi strati superficiali la materia
andrà ad arricchire le nubi
interstellari dal quale si formeranno le
nuove stelle
e qui vedete per esempio le delle
immagini di stelle neonate di stelle
appena formate studiate dall'off hubble
space telescope
in queste immagini hanno una
caratteristica forma discoidale perché
le stelle si formano all'interno di
dischi di gas di acqua di polveri dai
quali si formano i pianeti
noi adesso sappiamo che quasi tutte le
stelle hanno pianeti ma noi siamo
particolarmente affezionati al nostro
sistema planetario quello che si è
formato circa cinque miliardi di anni fa
intorno a una stella normalissima che
noi chiamiamo sole il nostro sistema
planetario è fatto da quattro pianeti
rocciosi vicino al sole e quattro
pianeti gassosi giganti gassosi lontani
dal sole
il la formazione planetaria
tuttavia non è un una via a senso unico
non è una via sempre tranquilla a volte
piuttosto tumultuosa e lascia morti e
feriti e quindi il nostro sistema solare
è effettivamente pieno di rimasugli
rimasugli che
presto tardi
entrano in contatto con i pianeti e in
effetti quello che dovete sapere che
tutti i pianeti del sistema solare non
sono sistemi isolati ma raccolgono
materiale per esempio sulla terra ogni
anno cadono 40.000 tonnellate di
materiale extraterrestre non c'è da
spaventarsi
è dall'inizio dei tempi che questo
succede è quello che ci dobbiamo
chiedere che tipo di materiale lo vedete
in questo
in questa immagine di fantasia questi
sassetti celesti sono un po come le
magliette del ted cortina sono di tutte
le taglie e si va dall extrasmall al 3xl
e ognuno di questi interagisce
diversamente con l'atmosfera
i più normali diciamo quelli di gran
lunga più numerosi sono i granelli di
polvere quando interagiscono con
l'atmosfera si incendiano e fanno una
scia luminosa sono le stelle cadenti le
avete viste pochi giorni fa c'è stato il
picco delle perseidi
e se siete affezionati alle stelle
cadenti sicuramente le avrete ammirate
dei sassi celesti un pochino più grandi
fanno delle scie più grandi quelli
ancora più grandi esplodono
nell'atmosfera fanno un gran botto
se esplodono in in zone abitate
abbiamo dei bellissimi filmati di questi
gran botti
questo è
il filmato del l'esplosione che è
avvenuta nel febbraio 2013 in siberia
sopra la città di celiabinsk il sasso
celeste che quando è entrato
nell'atmosfera pesava circa 10mila
tonnellate e quindi è un sasso di
dimensioni circa 15 metri più grande di
questa stanza è come dicevo esploso come
sempre succede in questi casi il pezzo
più grande è andato a finire in un lago
ghiacciato facendo un bel buco è stato
poi recuperato quando i ghiacci si sono
sciolti ma i bambini della regione di
celiabinsk e hanno giocato per giorni e
giorni alla ricerca dei pezzettini
cosmici che poi qualcuno ha venduto su
internet il questo è il buco lasciato il
cratere lasciato da un meteorite
decisamente più grosso il meteor crater
in arizona
ma la madre di tutte le nostre paure per
quanto riguarda l'impatto di oggetti
celesti è sicuramente il l'evento che i
66 milioni di anni fa ha fatto
estinguere i dinosauri
ora abbiamo ragione ad avere paura di un
evento di questo tipo
la risposta è no ed è no per due motivi
primo perché e gli asteroidi così grandi
a questo punto sono tutti mappati nel
sistema solare e nessuno di essi è in
rotta di collisione con la terra
secondo motivo di tranquillità
dovete pensare che se nessuno avesse
tolto di mezzo i dinosauri noi non ci
saremo perché i dinosauri i mammiferi li
mangiavano quindi a qualcuno ha tolto di
mezzo i lucertoloni ei mammiferi sono
esplosi quindi non dobbiamo seguire
l'esempio di asterix
non c'è bisogno di andare in giro con il
menhir perché asterix obelix aveva paura
che il cielo gli cascasse addosso la
preoccupazione di un impatto di
asteroidi è una preoccupazione
assolutamente esagerata e ricordatevi
che la probabilità di morire per
l'impatto di un meteorite è molto minore
di quella di essere divorati da un
pescecane nessuno di voi ha paura di
essere divorato da un pescecane
quindi per favore non abbiate paura di
morire per l'impatto di un meteorite
volevo finire dice parlandovi di che
cosa succede ai sassi celesti di
dimensioni un pochino più grandi della
polvere ma decisamente più piccoli di
quelli che fanno i bolidi sono
moltissimi questi questi piccoli sassi
celesti che entrano nell'atmosfera
ricordatevi che tutti i propri celesti
più o meno vanno a velocità dell'ordine
di 20 chilometri al secondo
quindi quando entrano nell'atmosfera
subiscono un attrito terrificante si si
scaldano moltissimo e evaporano si
vaporizzano istantaneamente quindi
abbiamo una nuvoletta di vapori che
possono essere vapori ferrosi e vapori
silicei a seconda di che cosa hai fatto
il sasso celeste e questi i vapori si
condensano perché sono in un nell'alta
atmosfera fa molto freddo meno 50 gradi
e formano delle microsferule delle
microsferule grandi come i nostri
capelli o anche più piccole
queste microsferule agiscono come centri
di condensazione per la pioggia e per la
neve quindi quando piove quando nevica
queste microsferule cadono al al suolo
quindi iniziamo a cortina siete abituati
a veder i tetti coperti di neve quando
la neve si scioglie
arriva la primavera l'acqua evapora e
nelle grondaie rimane terriccio sporco
che che magari dovete pulire in questo
terriccio ci sono sicuramente le
microsferule ma tutti avevano sempre
pensato che era assolutamente
impossibile riuscire a estrarre le
microsferule celesti da tutta la polvere
terrestre invece un suonatore di james
in di oslo che si chiama john lance ha
deciso che lui voleva provarci è andato
in giro a recuperare tutto lo sporco
delle grondaie di oslo che ha trovato e
ha messo insieme tre quintali di
sporcizia varia ed eventuale si è
chiesto come poteva riconoscere le
ferule celesti da quelle terrestri
approvato si è fatto aiutare da magneti
da luce polarizzata ha passato ore e ore
al microscopio e ce l'ha fatta ha
trovato 500 microsferule per un gran
totale di un grammo è partito da tre
quintali quanti grande ci sono in tre
quintali in un quintale ci sono 100 kg
in un chilo ci sono mille grammi 300.000
g per arrivare ad avere un grammo di
sfere celesti
ma sono bellissime lavorando al
microscopio le ha
fotografate e poi è vedete questi sono i
diversi colori che vede ma poi è un è un
suonatore di jazz ha fatto questo
filmato con tutte le sue bellissime
microsferule vi invito questo filmato in
rete vi invito a guardarlo perché è
veramente molto poetico e mentre lo
guardate pensate che voi queste
microsferule le avete sicuramente
respirate le avete sicuramente mangiate
quindi queste microsferule vi hanno
fatto diventare e ci hanno fatto
diventare tutti un pochino
extraterrestri quando riuscirete perché
si apriranno le nubi a vedere il cielo
quindi pensate che c'è veramente un
rapporto diretto tra le stelle e e
l'umanità e quando appunto vi fate
prendere dalla bellezza dello dello
spettacolo
dovete sempre pensare che non c'è un
dentro e un fuori non c'è un sopra è un
sotto quando voi guardate le stelle ma
c'è un tutto perché noi siamo parte di
un tutto e le microsferule ce lo
ricordano ogni momento grazie
[Applauso]